Prof: So I'll tell you a
little bit about Harold Bloom's
career later in the lecture.
Those of you who know How to
Read a Poem,
the books on religion,
Shakespeare and the
Invention of the Human,
and perhaps only know those
books, may feel a little
surprised at finding him on a
literary theory syllabus,
but the great outpouring of
work beginning with The
Anxiety of Influence,
A Map of Misreading,
Poetry and Repression,
and a great many other books in
the seventies put Bloom in the
very midst of the theoretical
controversies then swirling.
He was associated with the
so-called Yale School.
In fact, he was willing to put
his name as editor and also a
contributor on a volume that was
called Deconstruction and
Criticism.
I think though that,
even in reading what you have
before you, you can see how
relatively little Bloom has to
do with deconstruction.
Certainly in his more recent
career he's distanced himself
from theory.
He hasn't really changed his
views of anything,
although he doesn't any longer
read poems through the machinery
of the six revisionary ratios.
Perhaps I should stop there and
say the six revisionary ratios
won't be on the test.
>
Now I think that nothing could
be more exciting than to
understand clinamen,
tessera, sort of kenosis,
askesis, demonization,
apophrades--whoa!--and to
wander in the realms of these
ideas,
and actually to use them as the
machinery for practical
criticism: to take a poem and to
see what you can actually do
with these ideas really is,
and I'm serious,
an exciting process.
You may very much resent not
having these six ratios on the
exam, and you may wish to hear
more about them.
You'll hear something about a
few of them in passing today,
but if you do wish to hear more
about them,
perhaps your sections will
>
provide some guidance.
In any case,
the contributions of Bloom to
theory in my opinion,
and I hope to bring this out in
the long run,
have primarily to do with the
fact that I think he can
legitimately and authentically
be called an important literary
historiographer.
That is to say,
together with people like
Tynjanov and Jakobson earlier in
the course and Hans Robert Jauss
later in the course,
Bloom does seriously deserve to
be considered a literary
historian--
that is to say,
a person with a theory about
literary history on a par with
those other figures.
This hasn't always often been
remarked.
As a matter of fact,
the general critical attitude
toward Bloom is that he's
hopelessly ahistoricist,
cares nothing about history,
and cares nothing about the way
in which the real world impinges
on literature.
In a certain measure,
as we'll also see,
there is some truth in this,
but he has a powerful argument
about the relationship among
texts as they succeed each other
in history.
It's an argument which I think
really we ignore in our peril.
It's an important one and it is
a psychoanalytic one,
which is one of the things that
places him at this point in the
course.
You'll remember the sort of
tripartition of the subject
matter of our course which--
it's all headed up in the
syllabus and all clearly to be
understood.
First we have logo genesis,
the production of literature by
language.
Then we have psychogenesis,
the production of literature by
the human psyche.
Then we have sociogenesis,
the production of literature by
social, economic,
and political and historical
factors.
Okay, fine, well and good,
but you may have noticed how
much trouble we have had getting
into psychogenesis.
We keep saying we've arrived
>
at psychogenesis,
but we actually continue to be
working obviously with
linguistic models.
Here is Lacan telling us the
unconscious resembles a
language, that it's structured
like a language;
Brooks telling us that it's the
verbal structure arising out of
the relationship between
metaphor and metonymy that
constitutes the narrative text.
We keep sitting around
twiddling our thumbs,
waiting for somebody to say
something about the
psychogenesis of the text.
Well, Bloom brings us closer,
and he himself,
when he speaks of the poet in
the poet,
is concerned to describe what
he calls an "agon,"
a psychological agon or
struggle between the belated
poet and the precursor taking
place at that level in the
psyche;
but even Bloom,
of course, is talking about the
relation of text to text.
He is talking about relations
which are arguably verbal.
Verbal influence,
by the way, he always professes
contempt for.
He calls it moldy fig
philology, but I think that as
you study the examples of
literary influence in Bloom's
text,
Anxiety of Influence,
A Map of Misreading and so
on,
you will see that there is a
kind of dependence on verbal
echo and verbal continuity,
and that his theory,
the strong version of his
theory,
struggles against but,
I think, nevertheless does link
itself to.
I want to move into a general
exploration of the topic of
influence by talking,
in fact, about how unstable the
relationship between an idea of
influence which is,
let's say, psychological or
world-based and an idea of
influence which is word-based
can be.
It's not as simple and
straightforward a distinction as
one might imagine.
So we linger in these
linguistic models and there's a
long tradition in which the
confusion between the psychic
and the linguistic is manifest,
and it has to do with the very
traditional subject of
imitation.
Plato and Aristotle agree that
art, poetry, is an imitation.
It is, both of them say,
an imitation of nature.
Plato thinks it's done badly,
Aristotle thinks it's done
well, but both agree that poetry
is an imitation of nature.
Then as time passes,
this idea of mimesis,
the imitation of nature,
gradually becomes transformed
so that by the time you get to
the Silver Age of Roman
literature,
a high-water mark of elegance
in the Latin language,
you have rhetorical theorists
like Quintilian and Cicero and
others talking not about mimesis
but about--
in Latin, of
course--imitatio,
seemingly the same idea.
They are still talking about
imitation, but the strange thing
that's happened is now they're
not talking about the imitation
of nature anymore.
They're talking about the
imitation of literary models:
in other words,
the imitation of language,
the way in which we can
establish canons by thinking
about the relationship of
particular poets and other
writers with a tradition of
literary expression from which
they emerge.
So this then,
imitatio,
becomes a language-based theory
of influence arising seemingly
spontaneously out of a
nature-based theory of
influence.
Now take a look at the first
passage on your sheet from
Alexander's Pope's "Essay
on Criticism."
He's talking about Virgil here.
Homer, the argument is,
has to have imitated nature.
After all, there were no
literary models to imitate,
so if Homer imitated anything
it must have been nature.
Well, fine.
Homer imitated nature,
but then along comes Virgil--
in this same period,
by the way, when rhetorical
theories were redefining
imitation as the imitation of
verbal models--
along comes Virgil and he says,
"I'm going to write my own
national epic and you know what,
I'll just sit down and write
it."
But then he starts looking at
Homer;
this is all what Pope is
thinking as he prepares to write
the couplet that's on your
sheet.
Then he starts to write,
but then he rereads Homer.
At first he feels terrible
because he realized that Homer
has said it all.
There are two poems,
The Iliad and The
Odyssey.
There's nothing left to say.
Homer has covered the entire
waterfront, and so Virgil is
sort of stuck.
What is he going to do?
Well, what he can do,
if he can't imitate nature
anymore because Homer has done
that, is he can imitate Homer.
The result is that he comes to
a sort of realization that Pope
epitomizes in this couplet:
But when t' examine ev'ry part
he came [that is to say,
every part of Homer's
compositions,
every part of his own
composition as he undertook to
write his own epic]
Nature and Homer were,
he found, the same.
So here you have emerging the
idea that to imitate nature and
to imitate art--
to imitate the things of the
world,
the people of the world,
and to imitate language--
is part and parcel of the same
process.
To do one you necessarily and
perforce do the other.
That's what I mean by saying
that we're still struggling to
get away from the logogenetic
>
model to the psychogenetic
model.
Even in the most traditional
expressions of how influence
works,
like Pope's,
we are still concerned to
distinguish,
and find it very difficult to
between nature and art.
When Samuel Johnson,
fifty years after Pope,
is still saying,
"Nothing can please many,
or please long,
but just representations of
general nature,"
he is in this idea of
representations and in the idea
of general nature teetering
between a sense that it's things
in the world that art imitates
and it is existing literary
models that art imitates and
from which art takes its cue.
So there's a kind of collapse
then in the idea of imitation.
There's a kind of a collapse,
a surprising collapse perhaps
when you think about it,
between the notion of the
imitation of nature and the
notion of the imitation of art.
Now if we turn then to the two
texts that you've read for
today, both of which are
theories of influence,
you can see that T.S. Eliot,
too, is a little bit unclear as
to the relationship of these two
sorts of imitation.
For Eliot the individual talent
that inserts itself into,
that engages with,
tradition has to cope with what
Eliot calls "the mind of
Europe,"
page 539,
left-hand column.
I'll read a fairly extensive
passage because this is one of
the most accessible summaries of
what Eliot has to say:
[The poet]
must be quite aware of the
obvious fact that art never
improves, but that the material
of art is never quite the same.
He must be aware that the mind
of Europe--
the mind of his own country--a
mind which he learns in time to
be much more important than his
own private mind…
Let me just stop there and say
this seems as much unlike Bloom
as it can possibly be because
Bloom,
the Romantic,
is all about one's own private
mind,
the struggle of the individual
mind to define itself over
against all of those minds
jostling for attention that
precede it to over them to the
point where they are,
in effect, effaced,
and the belated ego can finally
establish itself as prior to all
preceding egos.
This sort of struggle
seems--and I say
"seems"
because I'm going to be
lingering over this for a
while--
seems to be absent from Eliot.
Eliot seems to be all about
self-effacement,
about the recognition that the
mind of Europe is more important
than one's own mind,
and that if one is to
contribute anything as an
individual talent to tradition,
that contribution has to be a
matter of the most acutely
sensitive awareness of
everything,
not that one is struggling to
be but that one is not.
It seems, in other words,
like a very different
perspective.
To continue the passage:
… [The mind of Europe
is]
a mind which changes,
and that this change is a
development which abandons
nothing en route which does not
superannuate either Shakespeare
or Homer,
or the rock drawing of the
Magdalenian draftsman.
That this development,
refinement perhaps,
complication certainly,
is not, from the point of view
of the artist any improvement.
In other words,
the relationship between
tradition and the individual
talent is a relationship of
entering into a vast matrix of
literary,
philosophical,
and other sorts of expression
that changes and yet never
really transforms itself and
certainly can't be understood as
a grand march or progress toward
some great goal,
because nothing is ever lost
and nothing radically innovative
can ever really be introduced.
I hope you are thinking and
reflecting on a passage of this
kind about a good deal that
we've passed through already:
Gadamer's sense of tradition as
something which depends
absolutely on the awareness of
continuity,
on the willingness to meet the
past halfway,
to enter into a merger of
horizons in which the past and
the present can speak in an
authentic way to each other;
and that in other ways this
idea, or possibly also the
Russian formalist idea in its
Darwinian sense,
that the dominant and the
recessive elements of any
literary text are always present
at any time.
It's just that they tend
perpetually in a kind of
oscillation to be changing
places with each other.
So the whole gamut of literary
possibility,
of expressive possibility,
is, according to theories of
history of this kind,
is always already there,
and one's own entry into this
vast sea of expressive
possibility is always a subtle
thing that certainly can't in
any way be seen to showcase or
to manifest any sort of original
genius as the Romantic tradition
might want to insist on it.
So this is basically the
perspective of Eliot and one
from which certainly you know
Bloom would obviously seem to be
diverging.
Now I want to argue that
actually there is a tremendous
amount of continuity between
Eliot and Bloom,
and that Bloom's
>
Anxiety of
Influence--I've never
discussed this with Harold,
by the way.
Those of you who may be taking
his seminars,
I leave it up to you whether
you want to take this up with
him.
As I say, I leave that up to
you, but I think a strong
argument can be made,
and I have made it in print so
Harold has seen it,
that Bloom misreads and is a
strong misreader of
T.S. Eliot:
which is to say--such is the
logic of strong misreading--that
T.S. Eliot said everything
Bloom has to say already.
I do believe this,
>
despite this extraordinary
appearance of total difference
in perspective,
the traditional versus the
Romantic and so on.
I don't want to go into detail
in this argument for fear of
being considered obsessive,
but I'd like to make a few
points about it in passing,
because I think it's such a
perfect exemplification of how
The Anxiety of Influence
works.
Bloom has always denied the
influence of "Tradition in
the Individual Talent."
He acknowledges influences,
but they are Emerson,
Nietzsche, the great Romantic
poets, and so on.
He has, as I say,
vehemently denied the influence
of Eliot,
yet as one reads Eliot--and I'm
going to spend some time with
Eliot now--
it seems to me that at least in
skeletal form,
in suggestion,
Bloom is all there already,
which is, after all,
all Bloom ever says about the
relationship between a precursor
and a belated writer:
so it can't be surprising,
can it?
All right.
Now first of all,
it's very important to Bloom to
show the way in which the new
reconstitutes the old:
that is to say,
the appropriation of the
precursor text,
which is not a notional text
although it--
and that's one of the things
that's sort of counterintuitive
about Bloom's writing in this
period.
He insists that there is a
particular precursor text.
The precursor text for
"Tintern Abbey"
is "Lycidas."
Don't tell me about other
>
precursor texts.
It's "Lycidas,"
and he shows how this is the
case,
but the relationship between
the belated text and the
precursor text is such that we
can never read the precursor
text the same way again.
The strong misreading of the
precursor text is so powerful,
in other words,
that it becomes our strong
misreading.
We just can't think about
"Lycidas"
in the same way on this view
after we've read "Tintern
Abbey."
If this seems counterintuitive,
just think about certain
examples that might come to
mind.
The most obvious example is the
famous text by Borges called
"Pierre Menard,
Author of Don
Quixote."
I imagine a number of you know
that text,
but what it consists in
basically is--
it's a kind of an anecdote
about a Frenchman writing,
as I recall,
in the end of the nineteenth
century in Spanish a text,
and his text is as it turns out
verbatim,
word for word,
Cervantes' Don Quixote,
only it's not Cervantes' Don
Quixote;
it's Pierre Menard's Don
Quixote.
Think how different it is.
This is a Frenchman at the end
of the nineteenth century
writing in Spanish.
That's pretty impressive,
much more impressive than
Cervantes merely writing in his
own language,
and it's a completely different
historical perspective.
Whereas Cervantes thinks he's
being a little bit ironic about
his own historical moment--
the death of chivalry and all
that--
think about how ironic you can
be about that historical moment
writing several centuries later
with everything that you know
now.
What a tour de force to be able
to write Don Quixote at
the end of the nineteenth
century in another language,
a whole new ball game!
How can you ever read
Cervantes' Don Quixote in
the same way?
It seems naïve, right?
Now that's not the point of the
story.
The point of the story is
actually to belittle Pierre
Menard, but you can see this as
a theory of strong misreading.
Pierre Menard thinks he's doing
something new,
right?
The fact is,
he's not doing anything new at
all.
His belief that he's doing
something new is precisely his
misreading of the precursor
text--
and by the way,
you don't have to have read the
precursor text--
but that misreading,
after all, is something in its
very power which,
as it were, infiltrates our own
understanding of the precursor
text,
making it impossible for us to
read it the same way again.
Think of Joyce's Ulysses.
We all know that
Ulysses,
like Virgil's Aeneid,
is based on The Odyssey
and that it, as it were,
recycles The Odyssey;
but it seems to be looking at
The Odyssey through the
wrong end of a telescope.
It's dragging all the sort of
heroic dimension of the poem
down into a kind of nitty-gritty
account of everyday life in
recent society.
In other words,
it implicitly,
precisely in following The
Odyssey debunks the heroic
myth of The Odyssey.
How can we read,
in other words,
The Odyssey in the same
way again after we've read
Ulysses?
Now it has to be said,
and Bloom would say this,
Ulysses is not a strong
misreading of The Odyssey
because it's perfectly conscious
of what it's doing.
It knows exactly what it's
doing with respect to the text
of The Odyssey, so
it's a deliberate misreading
which has other virtues.
It's not quite the same thing,
but what it does have in common
with Bloom's theory and what it
has in common also with Eliot's
idea about the relationship
between the individual talent
and tradition is that it
reconstitutes tradition.
It doesn't just provide
something novel.
It makes us see tradition
itself in a different way.
Turn to page 538,
the right-hand column about
halfway down:
The existing monuments [says
Eliot]
form an ideal order among
themselves which is modified by
the introduction of the new (the
really new) work of art among
them.
The existing order is complete
before the new work arrives;
for order to persist after the
supervention of novelty,
the whole existing order must
be, if ever so slightly,
altered.
We can't quite see it the same
way again,
so it's a dynamic,
mutual relationship between
tradition and the individual
talent: the strong precursor and
the belated poet,
in each case,
which is mutually transforming.
The basis, the principle of
transformation,
is the belated poet's strong
misreading of the precursor
which simultaneously asserts the
egoistic priority of the belated
poet: I'm doing something new;
I'm going where no one has ever
gone before.
I'm doing so so powerfully that
it's a question of whether there
actually was anybody before,
on the one hand,
and the strong precursor who
turns out,
as one reflects more and more
and more about the relationship,
to have said everything the
belated poet says already,
right?
So simultaneously,
Bloom's theory of literary
history,
his literary historiography,
places a premium on innovation
and on conservatism,
or tradition, simultaneously.
Unlike Gadamer,
leaning toward the conservative
or traditional,
and Iser or the Russian
formalists,
who lean toward the innovative,
the Bloomian idea
simultaneously countenances the
idea of tradition as something
absolutely continuous and also
of tradition as something which
is constantly being remade or at
least rethought.
That, I have to tell you,
is very similar to
T.S. Eliot's position.
So now again the famous
aphorism of Eliot on page 539,
the left-hand column at the
bottom:
Someone said:
"The dead writers are
remote from us because we know
so much than they did."
Precisely, and they are that
which we know.
Rather good, I think.
The famous aphorism of
T.S. Eliot can also be
understood as something that
Bloom, in his own way,
might very well say.
The past is what we know,
but we're not aware of knowing
it.
In other words,
I write the past when I write
my belated poem,
but I don't think I'm doing it.
I think instead that I'm doing
something new.
In the first provisionary
ratio, clinamen,
I am swerving from the past:
I swerve out and down,
I find my own space like a
Lucretian atom.
If it weren't for swerving--and
Lucretius says all the atoms
would fall in the same place--
that wouldn't be good,
so they all swerve so they can
all fall in their own place.
Well, that is the belated
poet's sense of what he's doing
in relation to the precursor.
He's swerving out and down from
the precursor poet,
but of course he's not.
>
Again--and we'll come back to
this--he's not.
He's actually falling in the
same place,
but the strength of that
swerve, the rhetorical gesture
of the swerve,
is so powerful that we do feel
transported.
Once again we feel both at
once, the innovation and the
necessary conservatism,
or preservational aspect,
of the new poet's composition.
All right.
So I think, as I say,
that Eliot's aphorism,
too, very much anticipates
Bloom's view of the agonistic
struggle among poets.
Then finally Eliot's famous
emphasis--
and of course,
nothing could seem to be less
gloomy than this--
Eliot's famous emphasis on the
poet's impersonality,
on the wish to escape
personality: he says,
in the right-hand column,
page 541,
end of section two, "But,
of course, only those who have
personality and emotions know
what it means to want to escape
from these things"--
in other words,
to enter a world of art,
in effect, to abandon the sense
that what's important is my
personal psychological agony;
to enter, by contrast,
the mind of Europe;
to recognize the complete
insignificance of any individual
mind, certainly my own;
and to immerse oneself as a
poet, as an artist,
and as a creator,
if one can still retain this
term,
in that which is infinitely
more vast than one is oneself.
Well, that doesn't sound very
Bloomian, but look on page 1160,
the right-hand column,
at Bloom's fifth revisionary
ratio, askesis.
>
He's talking about what the
later poet, the belated poet,
does in order to find space for
himself.
What can I do in order to make
myself different from other
people?
Well, you'd think the answer
would be make yourself bigger
than anybody.
Wallace Stevens has a wonderful
poem called "Rabbit as King
of the Ghosts,"
and the rabbit swells up to
become so big that it just kind
of overwhelms everything.
I always think of this as
Bloom's belated poet,
but if you have askesis as one
of the authentic revisionary
ratios,
something very different is
happening to this same end.
About halfway through the
definition, definition five--and
by the way, the masculine
pronoun is something that Harold
has never apologized for.
What he means is that a poet is
gendered masculine but that,
of course, any woman can be a
poet.
We'll come back to distinctions
of that sort later.
He does think of Emily
Dickinson, for example,
as a strong poet.
Obviously, that's a
controversial aspect of Bloom's
work, but he uses the masculine
prologue unapologetically.
Of course, his theory is very
much caught up in the idea of
Oedipal conflict which,
as Freud is always being
criticized for,
is, unless you project it into
the realm of the symbolic as
Lacan and feminist Lacanians do,
undoubtedly a masculist idea.
If the essential generational
conflict of human beings is
between father and son,
well, obviously
>
problems can be seen to arise
from that, and in Bloom's
rhetoric, in his vocabulary,
the masculist Oedipal conflict
is still central.
In any case,
returning to this point about
the effacement of the self,
in the very act of trying to
find a place for oneself as an
innovator--
an effacement which,
however, once again seems to me
to catapult Bloom back into the
position of Eliot that he is
trying to misread strongly.
He says, "[The poet]
yields up part of his own human
and imaginative endowment."
In other words,
he curtails himself;
he shrinks himself;
he makes himself less than he
might have been,
of course, in order to be more
than he has been.
He yields up part of his own
human and imaginative endowment
so as to separate himself from
others including the precursor.
So in askesis--and also in
kenosis,
by the way--there is a
self-shrinking or
self-effacement on the part of
these particular moves of strong
misreading with respect to the
precursor.
It's not, in other words,
just a question of the rabbit
as king of the ghosts.
It's not a question of a
massive ego swelling to the
point where it fills all space.
It is more complicated than
that, and in being more
complicated it is frankly more
Eliot-like.
All right.
So turning then more directly
to Bloom, his career begins--it
has always involved a sense of
struggle in the relationship
among poets.
In his earliest
work--Shelley's
Mythmaking,
Blake's Apocalypse,
and The Visionary Company--
the idea of struggle was
embodied plainly as what he
called Protestantism.
In other words,
he saw the tradition he was
talking about arising in
relation to the Reformation,
that time when,
as I said in my thumbnail
history of hermeneutics,
everybody suddenly realized he
had his own Bible and his own
relationship with God:
in other words,
that time when human
individuality emerges,
which is also,
of course, called by many
others the emergence of the
bourgeoisie.
In that moment,
the idea of Protestantism--
purely in the sense,
as a character in Durrell says,
"that I protest"--
emerges so that each poet
takes, in some sense,
an adversary stance toward
previous literary models.
This is present in Bloom's work
from the beginning of his
career.
The word "Protestant"
gradually gives way to the word
"revisionary,"
and then that's the word that
he uses primarily in The
Visionary Company,
for example,
and then finally becomes the
notion of misreading.
The protest of the belated
figure is the protest which
takes the form of transfiguring
the precursor text in such a way
that one can find oneself to be
original.
It is an Oedipal struggle.
Now this idea of Oedipal
struggle, which is largely
unconscious, is not new to
Bloom, just quickly to review
the next three passages on your
sheet.
Longinus, the author whose
actual identity we cannot quite
determine but whose On the
Sublime,
an extraordinarily interesting
text,
is available to us to
read--I've got two passages from
him.
The first is:
As if instinctively [this is in
the moment of the sublime]
our soul is uplifted by the
true sublime.
[Fine.
That's what you would expect
anybody to say.]
It takes a proud flight and is
filled with joy and vaunting
[and this is where the surprise
comes]
as though it had itself
produced what it has heard.
In other words,
there's a kind of possession by
the other that takes place which
is simultaneously experienced
psychologically as possession of
the other, right?
It is speaking through me.
It's making me very excited
like a little kid.
They're watching TV,
somebody hits a home run,
and the little kid goes like
this [gestures]
and thinks he thought he hit
the home run.
He's completely into the
fantasy of being that hero,
right?
It's the same thing with the
response to something that we
haven't said,
such that in a certain moment
we think we have said it.
It's a mutual possession.
It possesses us,
causing the psychological
reaction that we think of
ourselves as possessing it.
It seems to me that there is
real insight in what Longinus is
saying and that it has an
important influence on Bloom's
position.
Another passage from
Longinus--and by the way,
I think what Longinus says here
is absolutely true:
Plato is constantly abusing
Homer,
and yet nothing can be easier
than to show the ways in which
the great Homeric actions and
even tropes help shape Platonic
thought.
It's a fascinating topic and
Longinus,
it seems to me,
again is exactly right about
it: "There would not have
been so fine a bloom of
perfection on Plato's
philosophical doctrines unless
he had with all his heart and
mind struggled with Homer for
primacy."
He even thinks in Bloomian
terms of that of wanting to be
first even though in some part
of your mind you know you're
second--
he even struggles for primacy,
showing perhaps too much love
of contention and breaking a
lance with him,
as it were, but deriving some
profit from the contest
nonetheless;
for as he says,
"This strife is good for
mortals."
Quickly, a more commonplace
example taking from
Sainte-Beuve,
a famous essay of his called
"What is a Classic?"--
which is all about influence.
There's a tradition of essays
called "What is a
Classic?"
Eliot wrote a great one in
1944, and these are very much a
contribution to the history of
the theory of influence.
So Sainte-Beuve writes:
Goethe spoke the truth when he
remarked that Byron,
great by the flow and source of
poetry,
feared that Shakespeare was
more powerful than himself [it's
true,
Byron was always abusing
Shakespeare]
in the creation and realization
of his characters.
He would have liked to deny it.
The elevation so free from
[this is Goethe talking]
egoism irritated him.
He felt when near it that he
could never display himself at
ease.
He never denied Pope because he
did not fear him.
He knew that Pope was [and you
know how short Pope was]
only a low wall by his side.
So in other words,
he chose as his literary model
somebody he knew he was better
than--
not true, by the way,
but he thought he was better
than Alexander Pope,
and he perpetually denied a
very, very powerful influence on
his writing,
quarreling constantly with
Shakespeare and bardolatry and
excessive love of Hamlet
and all the rest of it.
He's constantly sort of denying
any influence or power over
himself on the part of
Shakespeare.
He chooses, in other words,
for his precursor a weak
precursor instead of a strong
precursor.
All of this is a continuous
theme in the psychodynamic of
Bloom's theory as he elaborates
it.
So what complicates Bloom's
argument,
apart from the vocabulary and
the philosophical range of
thought,
is what I began with:
the traditional idea of
influence as an art-nature
problem,
trying to figure out,
in fact, whether the crisis of
influence is the sense of one's
orientation to nature,
one's ability to imitate nature
and have nature available to
one,
or whether it's word oriented,
which it seems to be more in
Bloom: the sense of one's
relationship with text.
But notice on page 1157 that
Bloom really doesn't want to say
it's just about text.
He doesn't really want to say
that it has exclusively to do
with the strong precursor
understood, as it were,
as an author.
There is in some sense a text
of nature as well,
so that Bloom says,
bottom of 1157,
right-hand column:
… Freud's disciple,
Otto Rank, show[s]
a greater awareness of the
artist's fight against art,
and of the relation of this
struggle to the artist's
antithetical battle against
nature.
In other words, nature is death.
Nature is that into
which--should he not sustain
himself in the triumph of his
assertion of priority nature--
the author will fall back in
the form of death.
Wait until they try to
transcribe that sentence.
Okay.
Well, but you
>
got what I mean.
This is an interesting problem,
and Bloom wants to insist that
part of the struggle of the
belated poet is a struggle for
immortality.
Part of what it means to come
first and to know nothing ever
having been there before you is
also to suppose that you are
going to be last,
that you're going to be
immortal, that you really do not
belong in an unfolding,
inexorable sequence of the sort
that we call history;
but that you are rather
something, a force,
a genius, or a power that
transcends history.
This entails as much the
"lie against time,"
as Bloom calls it,
holding off death as it does,
insisting on there having been
no beginning,
no priority,
and no genesis in what you do;
you were there first.
All right.
To illustrate this very
quickly, let's look at passages
five and six on your sheet.
Wordsworth, the particularly
important strong misreader and
belated poet with respect to
Milton,
in Bloom's view:
Wordsworth writes in a kind of
programmatic or promissory
poem--
written actually in 1800 and
not published until 1814 as part
of the preface to a poem of his
called "The
Excursion"--
he wrote a prospectus to
"The Recluse,"
that's what at one time
"The Excursion"
was supposed to be part of,
and he says:
"I am not interested in
writing Paradise Lost.
Paradise Lost for me is
a thing of the past.
It's just archaic.
Who would care about the things
Milton cares about:
'all strength,
all terror, single or in bands
that ever was put forth in
personal form,
Jehovah with his thunder and
the choir of shouting angels and
the imperial thrones,
I pass them unalarmed.'
Paradise Lost,
that's just playing with
toy soldiers.
That's nothing compared with
what I myself am going to do:
'not chaos,
not the darkest pit of lowest
Erebus nor aught of blinder
vacancy scooped out by help of
dreams can breed such fear and
awe as fall upon us often when
we look into our minds,
into the mind of man,
my haunt and the main region of
my song.'
I'm not talking about God.
I'm not talking about heaven.
I'm not talking about hell.
I'm not talking about war in
heaven.
I'm not talking about anything
mythological or archaically
heroic.
"I'm talking about this.
I'm talking about the mind of
man.
I'm talking primarily about my
mind, but my mind is your mind.
Mind is universal,
and in talking about mind I'm
not falling back into the pit of
nature.
I'm keeping my focus not on the
sky gods,
not on the "transcendent,
starry junk,"
as Wallace Stevens called it,
of my precursors,
all those people with their
outworn superstitions.
I'm not interested in any of
that, but I'm not interested in
any of this either.
I'm not interested in nature.
I'm not interested in that in
which I would be buried if I
reduced myself to that.
I am interested in
consciousness,
the psyche.
In other words,
my focus is,"
Wordsworth says,
"altogether
psychological."
All right.
No interest in Paradise Lost.
That's just archaic.
Well, look at passage five:
three statements by Satan which
Bloom insists--it's not so much
Milton, because Bloom follows
Blake and Shelley in this.
It's not so much Milton who is
the strong precursor of
Wordsworth.
It's actually Satan,
right?
>
It's Milton's Satan who says,
"The mind is its own place
and in itself can make a heaven
of hell, a hell of heaven."
Okay.
Gee whiz. >
I guess Satan is writing the
prospectus to "The
Recluse,"
isn't he,
because that's what Wordsworth
is saying in the prospectus to
"The Recluse."
"I know no time,"
says Satan, "when I was
not as now."
That's what the belated poet
always says, "I came
first."
Elsewhere in the poem Satan
tells his troops,
"You know what.
God keeps saying he created you.
Do you remember being created?
I don't remember being created.
I've always been there."
Right?
That is, in effect,
what he says again,
what he repeats in this
passage, "Finally,
myself am hell."
Well, that's,
of course, rather an
uncomfortable thing to say,
but at the same time it's the
rabbit as king of the ghosts,
isn't it?
It is whatever you can throw at
me, I'm it already.
Right?
Because "the main haunt
and sole region of my song is
the mind,"
is my own mind.
All right.
So Satan has already said in
Paradise Lost everything
Wordsworth can possibly say in
the prospectus to "The
Recluse."
He has strongly misread
Paradise Lost such that
he thinks he's doing something
completely new,
while revealing precisely that
the strong precursor poet has
always already written what the
successor poet can write.
The tension,
the dynamic in other words,
between conservation and
innovation is intact in all such
moments,
in all the moments,
that involve the anxiety of
influence.
I'm sorry I have so little time
for this.
Give me a minute or two because
we have to honor Tony the Tow
Truck, and it's
rather obvious that for Lacan,
Tony the Tow Truck is a
text in which Tony settles for
the objet petit a,
right: little Bumpy the Car,
an imperfect being but a
helpful one and a friend--
"that's what I call a
friend";
whereas the objects of desire,
Neato, Speedy--whoa,
those are cars.
The objects of desire are
improper object choices on the
face of it.
That's what an American ego
psychologist would say,
but they are,
in a more Bunuelesque way of
putting it,
obscure objects of desire as
they motor on down the road
which are simply unavailable to
Tony as object relations at all.
So Neato and Speedy are the big
other--right?--and Bumpy is the
object petit a.
All right.
Now it's just perfectly obvious
that for Harold Bloom,
Tony the Tow Truck is a
strong misreading of The
Little Engine that Could.
It's perfectly clear
because Bumpy is the hero of
The Little Engine that Could.
The misreading involves
making Tony the hero who needs
the help of Bumpy.
In other words,
Bumpy, in the folkloric sense
of the story,
becomes the helper and not the
hero,
but we can see,
after all, that the essential
narrative model--
the model of the small turning
out through perseverance and
energy to necessarily reinforce
the strength of the strong--
is about the strong and the
weak.
Both The Little Engine that
Could and Tony the Tow
Truck are about the strong
and the weak,
that the strong must in some
sense or another be supplemented
or supplanted by the weak if the
strong is fully to self-realize.
We can't ever read Tony the
Tow Truck,
the character,
Tony, quite the same way again
after the appearance of Bumpy,
and yet Bumpy is nothing other
than the hero of The Little
Engine that Could,
a subject position that has
been appropriated by Tony in
this text.
So the relationship is again an
agonistic one involving the
transposition of heroism from
one character-focus to another
while at the same time--
as anybody can recognize who
has read both stories to their
kids--
simply rewriting the story in a
way that The Little Engine
that Could completely
anticipates.
All right.
So much then for that.
We'll be returning to more
Lacanian pastures on Tuesday
when we study Deleuze and
Guattari and Slavoj Žižek.